[MUSIC PLAYING]
- I would now like to introduce
Catherine Wagner, Katie.
Katie is an assistant professor
in the Department of Biology
and Diversity Institute at
the University of Wyoming.
She is our fish person.
And I say that in the best way.
Katie will talk to us about
the evolution and diversity
of the East African
cichlid fish.
And I don't want to
take up too much time.
I have a whole thing I was
going to say about you,
but I'm going to actually have
you come up and give your talk,
since we're running very long.
[APPLAUSE]
- OK.
It's wonderful to
be here today, and I
am glad that I can take
the focus a little bit
away from humans and
move towards fish.
So just to introduce
you a little bit
to these fish called cichlids,
this is a family of fish.
They're diverse in South
America and in Central America.
They're also found in southern
India and in the Middle East.
And even if you don't think that
you are familiar with cichlids,
you may actually be familiar
with them on your plate,
because tilapia is
an African cichlid.
And tilapia is one of the
most commonly farmed fish
in the world.
So tilapia is one of many
thousands of cichlids
that live in Africa.
They're exceptionally diverse.
And within the East
African Rift Lakes
alone, there are more
than 1,500 endemic species
of cichlid fishes.
In the three Great Lakes,
Victoria, Tanganyika,
and Malawi, there is the
independent evolution
of hundreds of these cichlid
species in each of these lakes.
These fish have exceptional
diversity and ecology
and in morphology, and
they form independently
in each of these lakes what
we call adaptive radiations.
Adaptive radiations
are the rapid origin
of ecological and species
diversity via descent
with modification from
a common ancestor.
So this process of
adaptive radiation
has happened independently
in each of these three Great
Lakes, and also in
many other lakes
across the African continent.
So in this process of
adaptive radiation,
from a generalized ancestor
we have the evolution
of specialized ecology
such that, within each
of these cichlid
adaptive radiations,
we have the evolution
of fish that
are specialized to eat
scales of other fish,
fish that are specialized
to eat algae off
of rocks in all kinds
of different ways,
fish that have
funny fat lips that
help them eat invertebrates
between cracks in rocks,
other fish that have these
jaws in their throat called
pharyngeal jaws that
help them crush mollusks,
and also all kinds
of specializations
to eat other fish.
So these are what
we call piscivores.
You can also see that these
fish are exceptionally diverse
in color and in
body shape and size.
And the thing that I
want to emphasize here
is that, within these
cichlid adaptive radiations,
we're essentially
evolving entire food webs.
One thing I like to say is that
the only thing that cichlids
can't do is photosynthesize.
So we're evolving everything
from the primary consumers
in these ecosystems up
to the top predators
in these ecosystems.
And this is, as I
mentioned before,
happened in dozens of lakes
across the African continent.
And this plot, in
the red, shows lakes
where there has
been the evolution
of endemic cichlid species.
And then gray shows lakes where
there are cichlid species,
but no endemic species
have evolved there.
So if we were to draw an analog
with another famous example
of adaptive radiation,
these are Darwin's finches
from the Galapagos.
And Darwin's finches
are famous because,
from a single common
ancestor in the Galapagos,
there has evolved about 18
species that have diverse bill
morphologies that
allow them to eat
all sorts of different things.
If we were to draw an analogy
between Darwin's finches
and cichlids, this would be
as if Darwin's finches had
done this not only once
but dozens of times,
and if some of these
Darwin's finch radiations
had hundreds of species
instead of the 18 species
that currently exist there.
So this lends itself to
thinking about African cichlids
as a grand natural experiment,
where we can ask questions
like, why do adaptive
radiations happen sometimes
and not others?
And what determines the
number of species that evolve
within adaptive radiations?
So I'm going to touch
on three questions
today that are
related to research
that I've been working on.
The first is, what predicts
when adaptive radiations happen?
The second is, what influences
the number of species
that evolve within these lakes?
And then third, what
enables exceptionally rapid
diversification in some cases?
So if we look at the
diversity of cichlids
across the African continent,
we can identify 38 times
where cichlids
have entered a lake
and then subsequently
diversified.
But we can identify
another 145 times
where a species
has entered a lake
and has failed to diversify.
So this data set us up
to ask the question,
why do some lineages
diversify while others don't?
So to address this
question, we put together
a data set including traits
of these species that
were hypothesized to
influence speciation,
the origin of new
species within cichlids.
So these are intrinsic
factors, factors
related to the biology
of the organisms.
We also included a lot
of potential predictors
from the environment, aspects
of the lakes themselves,
the environment that
these fish encounter
when they colonize a lake.
And so these are
extrinsic factors.
And when we analyze all of these
potential predictors and models
together, we invariably find
that the best models include
both intrinsic and
extrinsic factors
in predicting when cichlid
adaptive radiations happen.
And so this leads
us to a picture
of thinking about cichlid
adaptive radiations
as happening as an interaction
between the intrinsic biology
of the organisms
and the environment
that they encounter.
Specifically, three
of the predictors
that come out as strong positive
influence on cichlid adaptive
radiation are the depth of
the lake that the cichlids are
found in; energy, so this
is solar radiation hitting
the lake; and also the presence
of sexual dichromatism, which
is differences in colors
between males and females.
And that strength of
sexual dichromatism
is often related to the
strength of sexual selection
that operates in these
cichlid lineages.
And in particular, we were
interested to find both depth
and sexual dichromatism
as predictors
of adaptive radiation
because both of those aspects
are involved in one of the
best studied mechanisms
of cichlid speciation, which
is known as sensory drive
speciation.
This is where there's
differential adaptation
along depth gradients
in lakes, where
at deeper depths in a
lake the fish are living
in a very different
light environment
than the fish have at the
shallow part of the lake.
And this drives differential
ecological adaptation and also
differential sexual selection,
which leads to speciation.
So finding this pattern of both
depth and sexual dichromatism
at a broader scale for cichlids
suggests that this mechanism
may operate across
the continent,
and help us to explain cichlid
diversity more generally.
We were also interested
to find energy
coming out as a predictor of
cichlid adaptive radiation.
And although this hadn't
ever been discussed
in cichlid biology
before, we know
that energy
availability would have
a strong influence on
resource environment
and on population abundances,
and both of those aspects
we would expect to play into
the evolutionary biology
of these fish.
So this presents
lots more questions
to ask about the relationship
between energy availability
and evolution.
And one thing I want to
mention before moving on
is that these models are only
as good as the predictors
that we can include in them.
And there are certainly
other predictors
which are also really important
in explaining cichlid adaptive
radiation.
One of those that is emerging
as incredibly important
is genetic diversity
of these lineages
and their history
of hybridization.
And that's a subject that I'll
speak about towards the end
of the talk.
I also want to point out
that surface area of lakes
does not predict whether
or not cichlid adaptive
radiations happen, but surface
area becomes very important
when thinking about predicting
the number of species
that evolve within these
adaptive radiations.
So that's the second part of the
talk, asking the question, what
influences the number
of cichlid species
that evolve in
these African lakes?
So in this plot
of Africa, you can
see the red dots correspond
to lakes where there has
been evolution of new species.
The black dots are lakes
where there has not been
the evolution of new species.
And the size of the dot
corresponds with the number
of species in that lake.
And you can see that these
lakes range in species number
from many hundreds of species
down to just a few species.
So we can think of the number
of species in these lakes
in a couple of different ways.
Some lakes, the species that
are there simply because they've
colonized the lake.
They've dispersed into
the lake from rivers,
and so this would be a
dispersal assembled community.
We have other communities
where there's been evolution
of one of those colonists.
And so we can think of this
as an evolution assembled
community.
And in these cichlids,
sometimes this evolution
has happened in one
lineage, and sometimes it's
happened in multiple
lineage to contribute
to the number of species
that we find in that lake.
If we plot the number of
lineages we find in the lake--
so this is the number
of species, essentially,
as a function of lake area.
And this is not accounting
for the effects of evolution.
So this is cutting
out all the species
that have evolved in place.
We see that there's a
positive relationship here.
So we get more
species in the lake
simply the bigger the lake is.
More species colonize into it.
But if we then add on
the effects of evolution,
what we see is that evolution
within these lakes produces
on average an order of magnitude
more species in these lakes
than dispersal alone.
So evolution is having a
gigantic impact on the number
of species within these lakes.
And additionally,
more species evolve
in the very largest lakes.
So we can predict
the number of species
that evolve in a lake based
on the size of that lake.
If we take this one
step further and ask,
how does the rate at
which species evolve
influence these patterns?
This is a plot of
diversification rate
as a function of lake area.
And what you can see here
is that diversification rate
does not predict the number
of species in these lakes.
So there is no relationship
between diversification rate
and lake size.
There is one clear
outlier in this plot,
and that is Lake Victoria.
And if we look at the plot of
species richness in lake area,
and look at where Lake
Victoria is on that plot,
we can see that Lake
Victoria cichlid
diversity is exceptional,
because it both has
an exceptionally rapid
diversification rate,
and because the
lake is very large.
And so that points us to
Lake Victoria as an outlier,
and begs the
question, what enables
this exceptionally
rapid diversification
in the case of Lake Victoria?
And so this question
about the exceptional rate
of evolution in Lake Victoria
is actually an old one
in evolutionary biology.
And Lake Victoria is less
than 15,000 years old.
It was dry 15,000 years ago.
And it has about
450 cichlid species.
And this exceptional
rate of evolution
has led many people to
suggest that perhaps these
aren't actually
species, perhaps it's
just a hypervariable population,
and we shouldn't really
consider these species.
We used genomic data about five
years ago for the first time
to have a really in-depth look
at these species genetically.
And we find that, when we
use enough genomic data,
we can very readily tell
these species apart.
As you can see, each of
the species in this plot
forms nice groups when we
use enough genomic data.
So we really think
that these are
species as we would
consider anything a species.
And thanks to collaboration
with the Broad Institute,
we now have five fully sequenced
and annotated reference genomes
that span a lot of diversity
in African cichlids.
They're from many parts
of the African cichlid
evolutionary tree.
So using these resources
from the annotated reference
genomes, we can dig
further into understanding,
what are the genetic differences
between these young species,
and what are the
functional consequences
of those genetic differences?
This relates to the-- we've been
using this genomic information
to ask these questions about
the origins of exceptionally
rapid species diversity
in Lake Victoria,
specifically asking
the question,
where did this Lake Victoria
radiation come from?
And what genomic properties
facilitate this extremely rapid
radiation?
And the work that I'm
going to talk about now
is led by Joana Meier, who
is now a postdoctoral fellow
at Cambridge.
So Lake Victoria
is part of a larger
group of cichlids called
the Lake Victoria Region
Superflock.
This includes cichlid
adaptive radiations
in Lake Albert, Lake
Edward, Lake Kivu, and also
Lake Victoria.
So all of these
radiations together
form this group called the
LVRS, the Lake Victoria Region
Superflock.
And this comprises
about 700 species
that have evolved in
the past 150,000 years.
So the origins of this
group coincide roughly
with when modern humans
were leaving Africa,
to connect back to
our earlier talks.
So when we look at
the genomic data
from the Lake Victoria
Region Superflock,
using methods from
human genetics,
we infer that there was a
hybridization event between two
divergent lineages which
subsequently led to the Lake
Victoria Region Superflock.
And that hybridization event was
between the Congolese lineage,
whose distribution is
shown in red on the map
here, and an Upper Nile
lineage, whose distribution is
shown in this map in blue.
So these two lineages were at
least a million years divergent
from each other.
They encountered each other
in the Lake Victoria region,
and subsequently, all of
these adaptive radiations
in these different lakes in the
Lake Victoria region emerged.
So the question then becomes,
was this just a happenstance
event in their
history, or did it
have functional consequences?
Is there a functional
consequence
to this admixture in the same
way that we can ask questions
about the functional
consequences
of Neanderthal admixture
in human history?
And so one piece of
evidence pointing
to functional significance
of this hybridization event
comes from the LWS opsin gene.
LWS opsin is long
wavelength sensitive opsin.
So this gene is involved
in visual acuity
in different lighting
environments,
where one variant of the gene--
so this is the gene's diversity
in cichlids from the Lake
Victoria Region Superflock.
And we find, in some
species, a version
of the gene which gives
visual acuity in clear water
over rocky substrates.
And in other species in the
Lake Victoria Region Superflock,
a version of the gene which
provides visual acuity in murky
water and muddy substrates.
And so these different
versions of the LWS opsin gene
have been repeatedly
used for adaptation
to these different
light environments.
When we look at the
versions of the gene
present in the Congolese lineage
and in the Upper Nile lineage,
we see that all of the
Congolese lineage species
have the clear water
variant of the gene,
and all of the Upper
Nile lineage fish
have the muddy water
variant of the gene.
And so this suggests that the
reason that we find these two
variants of the gene together
in the Lake Victoria Region
Superflock is because of
this history of admixture
between the lineages.
So this lends
evidence to the idea
that this ancient
hybridization event
provided functional
genetic variation, which
was subsequently
used for adaptation
within these
adaptive radiations,
and facilitated the rapidity
at which these radiations could
happen.
So in summary, we think that
hybridization facilitates
cichlid evolution by providing
functional genetic variation
and enabling extremely
rapid adaptive radiation.
And we also think that these
kinds of hybridization events
may be quite pervasive in
cichlid evolutionary history,
and help to explain
rapid adaptive radiation
many times over.
So in summary, the take-home
points from my talk
are, first of all, that we
need to consider interactions
between intrinsic factors
and extrinsic factors
in predicting when
adaptive radiations happen.
Second, that lake area
predicts the number
of species that evolve
in African lakes,
and that that's
somewhat disconnected
from the diversification
rates in these lakes.
And third, that
hybridization may
be key in understanding
the exceptionally
rapid adaptive radiations
in African cichlids.
And with that, I'd like to thank
my collaborators and funders,
and I'd be happy to
take some questions.
[APPLAUSE]
- Thank you, Katie.
We have a question.
- What about a cichlid, compared
to other types of species,
makes it so good at
diversifying and adapting?
- Yeah.
That's a fantastic question.
And it's why so many of us
keep on studying cichlids,
because they're so exceptional.
If you look at other fish groups
in these lakes, some of them
have evolved a few
species here and there,
but nothing like
cichlids, nothing
like the hundreds of species
that we see in these lakes.
I don't think
there's one answer.
I think that there are
a number of features
of cichlids which facilitate
their rapid evolution.
But we would like to think
that some of these things
that I talked about--
propensity towards
sexual selection,
propensity of hybridization
events, and sharing
of these genetic variants
across divergent groups--
are some of the reasons why they
evolved so rapidly and so many
species.
- Thanks very much.
- Heather Remoff.
I'm wondering how the
species, the factors that
maintain species
integrity, are they
largely behavioral or genetic?
- Many of the features that
maintain species integrity
are behavioral.
So they're what we
would call prezygotic.
They're mate-choice decisions.
And so that's how hybridization
can happen very readily.
That's not to say that those
behavioral differences don't
have a genetic basis also.
- Alyssa?
- I am Alyssa Goodman
from here at Radcliffe,
and I was really admiring
your beautiful images of all
the fish, and it made
me wonder whether or not
there's a good correlation
between the genetic differences
and the actual
appearance of the fish.
Do the fish know that each
other are different species,
and can they even see
the colors of the fish?
- Yeah.
That's a great
question, and I wish
it was easier to ask every one
of those species this question.
So the mate-choice
decisions, as I've just said,
are a really crucial thing for
maintaining species boundaries
in many, many cases.
And so we know at
least in those cases
that they can tell
each other apart,
and that's very important for
the maintenance of diversity.
Yeah.
- Yes?
- I was just wondering
what is known--
this is Tim
[INAUDIBLE] from MIT.
Just wondering what is
known about horizontal gene
transfer in cichlids.
- Yeah, so in the case of
sexually reproducing organisms
like this, we think
of hybridization
as horizontal gene transfer.
That's our analog.
Yeah.
- We have two more minutes.
I have a question.
So you mentioned the energy
impacts the diversity.
Is that the same as temperature?
- It's not temperature.
So the proxy that we used was
solar radiation to these lakes,
which you would think
would have a direct impact
on productivity, so primary
productivity in these systems.
It would be fascinating
to have a global
or a continent-wide data set
on productivity instead of just
using solar
radiation as a proxy,
because there's all kinds
of complex limnology
that translates solar
radiation into the resource
base for these lakes.
- Is there information
on temperature?
- There is not--
we don't have information on
temperature in our system.
Again, that's another
thing that would
be great to have
for all these lakes.
- Right.
Well, that was fantastic.
And now we have
our last speaker.
Thank you, Katie.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]